bonjour voila vous vous trouvez sur
l'esplanade jean jaurès où les salariés
de renault se sont donné rendez vous
[Musique]
mais exactement ils sont sur cette
escalade protester contre la fermeture
de ce site qui existe depuis près de 70
ans plus de 260 salariés sont menacés
par cette fermeture d'ici 2022 il faut
savoir que parmi les 14 sites renault en
france est un des seuls qui va voir ses
portes se fermer d'ici 2020 de regarder
sur cet exploit n'est dit si de plus en
plus de monde
elles viennent se mobilisent et ici en
appel des organisations syndicales et
soutenu également par le maire de la
ville didier guillaume un maire pcf ici
à choisy-le-roi donc cette mobilisation
elle va commencer ici puis le cortège va
s'élancer dans les rues de la ville pour
atterrir finalement devant l' usine de
ce site je suis justement avec l'un de
ses salariés qui travaillent depuis près
de trente quatre ans bonjour bonjour à
vous georges merci d'être avec nous vous
le disiez sa cuisine c'est presque une
deuxième famille oui on nous sommes
dans l'entreprise une famille on a des
fois jusqu'à deux générations de l'âme
le père le fils
des fois les mêmes des beaux-frères les
beaux faire beau fils qui sont et qui
sont dans les caisses que représente
cette fermeture pour tous les salariés
ici puisqu'elle va être transféré dans
le 78 dans les yvelines à flins tout a
pas de problème c'est la distance
déjà on va être noyé dans un grand
machin comme dirait le grand charles
dans une usine immense alors qu'on est
une petite usine et surtout le
déplacement
physique aléas si loin que ça de chez
nous on est tous à implanter dans le
bassin et d'ici au plus haut plus on a
30 km voilà sa fermeture avait handicapé
des familles oui oui parce qu'il y aura
il ya des jeunes ya un jeune qui vient
juste d'acheter une maison il ya deux
mois il ya signé il ya deux mois et ça
ça va lui poser des gros gros problème
d'y aller là-bas alors on le voit il ya
une bonne mobilisation plusieurs
syndicats ja le maire de la ville autres
députés est ce que vous pensez que la
direction est à l'écouté
je suis du folklore pour
ils s'en foutent à partir du moment que
la direccte là
le pouvoir public ne rouspète pas il
s'ouvre pour eux c'est un épiphénomène
merci beaucoup à vous et d'avoir à
témoigner vous l'avez entendu des
salariés qui restent mobilisés et ça
depuis la semaine dernière ce n'est pas
la première mobilisation des salariés de
l'usiné de choisir cette fermeture est
bien elle fait partie du blanc économie
de l'industriel renault puisque dans le
monde entier 15000 emplois vont être
supprimés dont 4600 en france ici pour
pouvoir espérer économiser 2 milliards
d'euros d'ici à 2023
wang hao dès lors en direct de
choisy-le-roi merci moi là